a lo mejor has escuchado el término
labor o libor cuando la gente habla
acerca de tasas de interés dicen no me
voy a prestar tantos puntos arriba de la
word oa lo mejor oyes libor citado así
no sé en tu canal favorito de noticias
financieras pero simplemente de lo que
se trata es que es un promedio de las
tasas de interés en las cuales los
bancos se están prestando entre sí este
numerito es calculado por la asociación
de banqueros británicos bueno más bien
por thomson reuters pero por thomson
reuters para la asociación de banqueros
británicos para lo que sirve es para
establecer un umbral para otro tipo de
transacciones financieras y otros
valores las siglas quieren decir de
london interbank offered rate o sea en
londres es la tasa de oferta entre
bancos en londres es la tasa de oferta
interbancaria para entender es un poco
mejor dibuje por acá arriba dos bancos
hay un banco y un banco ve ahora a lo
mejor ya lo sepas pero la forma en la
cual los bancos hacen dinero es que tú
vas le deposita el dinero y luego ese
dinero lo usan para hacer préstamos no
sé digamos para algunos inversionistas
con cuánto efectivo se quedan pues nada
más con lo suficiente por si la gente
viene y quiere algo de efectivo para
gastar en su vida diaria ahora cómo te
lo puedes imaginar a lo mejor a un banco
le está pasando que se le acabe el
efectivo o que está muy cerca del
requisito de coeficientes de reserva del
país en el cual está ubicado y entonces
en esas situaciones no sé supongamos que
el banco está cercano a llegar a esa
situación en esas situaciones dice
necesito tomar prestado algo de dinero
voy a pedirle a algunos otros bancos
esto sería un préstamo interbancario por
ejemplo el banco verde por acá tiene
mucho efectivo y no quiere tener tanto
vaya le conviene más prestarlo porque no
se gana interés en las reservas sale
entonces el banco ve se anima a hacerle
un préstamo al banco a digamos que le
presta este tanto entonces esto de por
acá es el nuevo efectivo que tiene el
banco a da por ahí el nuevo efectivo y
por supuesto también ahora hay un
préstamo es un nuevo préstamo por pagar
recuerda los activos siempre son los
pasivos más el capital entonces sobre el
pasivo tiene que ser esta cosa de aquí
bueno entonces esto es préstamo de él
de el banco ve por este efectivo eso le
da un poco más de colchón citó en la
hoja de sus préstamos han aumentado pero
ese efectivo ha disminuido vale entonces
esto ahora de aquí es un préstamo tomó
este efectivo y lo pasó a un préstamo
para a va supongamos que la tasa con la
que le prestó a fue de un 1 por ciento
una tasa de 1 por ciento anual y vamos a
suponer que se tiene que renovar cada
día o sea es un préstamo por noche va
esta tasa es una tasa interbancaria
entonces lo que se hace a cargo de la
asociación de banqueros británicos es
que se hace una encuesta con diez o doce
bancos de londres van y les preguntan tú
cuál fue la tasa de interés con la cual
estuviste haciendo tus operaciones por
una noche lo promedia lo apuntan y eso
es el libor por una noche entonces no sé
a lo mejor hacer la encuesta y llegan a
que es 1.2 por ciento de todos los
bancos que entrevistaron y lo que está
interesante del libro es que está hecho
en 10 divisas no sólo en la libra
esterlina o el dólar o el yen está en 10
divisas y eso lo que realmente lo
diferencia bueno hay otras cosas pero
esta es una de las principales cosas que
lo diferencia de la tasa de fondos
federales efectivas de eeuu que es otra
tasa interbancaria pero de allá y que su
implementación es un poco distinta y
tiene más que ver con políticas
monetarias porque el banco central de
allá realmente hace cosas para cambiarla
nos vemos